dans ce qui semble bloquée avec les
socialistes notamment c'est la question
de l'union européenne olivier faur la
dîme il ne veut pas du mot désobéissance
sourire dans le compromis fin dans le
genre l'accord est ce que vous êtes
prêts justement à faire ce compromis est
enlevé ce mot désobéissance aux
retraités
laissons les négociateurs négocier donc
je ne vais pas vous dire quel est le
point de l'entente puisque le point
d'entente étant en discussion après je
veux dire ce qu'ils que ça signifie
derrière désobéir parce que ce que je
sais c'est que dans ces négociations
parfois il ya des incompréhensions des
préjugés on pense que l'autre ils
pensent ça voyez ce que j'ai en fait
c'est quand on commence à décortiquer à
démêler qu'on finit par se dire ben en
fait on n'est pas si pas d'accord que ce
qu'on pensait voyez ce que je veux dire
donc si on désobéit à fossa qu'est-ce
qu'on veut dire derrière ça ce qu'on
veut dire derrière ça c'est que si par
exemple en france on veut créer un pôle
public de l'énergie et que les traités
européens nous disent non il faut ouvrir
à la concurrence
eh bien nous on pense qu' il faut faire
ce pôle parce que les français nous ont
donné un mandat pour cela alors on le
fera c'est ça on appliquera pas les
normes des traités on appliquera la
politique conformément à la souveraineté
française populaire française sof
commence avec les mots ont un sens
surtout dans des accords comme ça
exactement du coup vous dites vous
expliquer voilà ce que vous voulez mais
le mot désobéissance une fois leur et je
suis en train tu en train de vous
répondre que ce sont aux négociateurs de
dire comment les socialistes et les
insoumis peuvent s'entendre sur le
vocabulaire mais ce sur quoi nous ne
bougerons pas c'est sur l'idée que je
viens de vous dire c'est à dire
concrètement nous estimons que si
l'union européenne nous empêchent de
mener des politiques de progrès social
et écologique alors nous n'appliquerons
pas ce ces impositions européenne voilà
cc on avait un congrès sur cette
question et ça gêne vous assurer qu on
bougera pas moi je veux bien qu'on
discute des mots mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que sur ce point mais ce que nous
demande si j'ai bien compris les
socialistes c'est aussi de savoir si ce
que nous voulons c'est demain un freak
site voilà les d'ailleurs avec europe
ecologie les verts c'est aussi ça la
discussion ça a été ça et nous avons
écrit noir sur blanc que l'enjeu n'était
pas une sortie immédiate de l'union
européenne et de la monnaie il m'aidait
à mixer pas non mais même immédiate ça
c'est pas c'est pas de notre jeu n'est
pas la sortie de l'union
voilà même avec le long terme c'est moi
là on est en effet sur le jeu rapport à
l'épée non mais c'est pas notre objectif
n'est pas celui là notre objectif est de
pouvoir appliquer notre politique sans
contrainte européenne qui nous amènerait
vers des régressions à la et de mener
bien sûr comme on l'a toujours dit la
bataille vous savez dans non de gauche
au début tu vois je vous raconte ça mais
c'est ça avoir un tout le débat public
c'était en fait le sujet c'est pour ou
contre l'europe c'était ça et les termes
du débat qu'on voulait nous imposer
c'était ça et c'est à partir du moment
où nous avons réussi à mettre sur la
table que l'enjeu c'était pas ça c'était
pour ou contre cette europe là et c'est
à ce moment là que le nom de gauche a
créé cette dynamique parce que parce
qu'au fond c'est pas qu'on ne veut pas
leur moi je pense que les politiques
menées actuellement c'est elle qui tue
l'europe c'est ça qui tuent leurs hommes
[Musique]